is this ally or potential comedy gold
Trump apparently wrote some of his
inauguration speech initial reports from
the hill and others say that Trump wrote
his inauguration speech himself I heard
this in thought yeah it's hilarious but
I can't really imagine Trump doing that
this is a guy who reportedly hasn't read
a whole book cover to cover in 40 years
he's gonna write a speech that will be
in history books for the remainder of
the existence of the US so then I looked
at the primary reporting about this by
CNN and they actually say Trump wrote
the draft of the speech himself
that's a drastically different scenario
you can write a draft and then actual
writers then make it into something that
makes any kind of coherent sense that
doesn't mean that he wrote it here's a
tweet that Trump sent out this is a
picture of him
apparently writing the inaugural speech
or something the real question is does
anybody believe that will Trump will
actually read off a teleprompter
tomorrow will be Trump's writing I would
say no because Trump writing and reading
his own speech without help would be an
unprecedented to use a word that Trump
coined disaster my hope is that at least
enough of the ideas of Trump's draft
make it into his speech and and and
actually stay after real writers get
their hands on it
I think president should at least draft
out the points that they want to make
sure their speech was laughable because
this is Donald Trump or at least some
bullet points written in crayon or
something I'll just do something you
know what I mean it's believable when we
hear President Obama wrote something
himself it's not believable when we hear
that Donald Trump wrote anything
resembling a finished draft of his own
speech it's also not believable because
during the entire campaign there were
basically two situations one is there's
no written speech at all Trump shows up
goes off-the-cuff sometimes just
insulting people or reading tweets or
saying someone in the crowd that's my
African American or sometimes he would
show up with a stack of polling data and
just read polls which was kind of boring
in my opinion the other configuration
was Trump senior policy advisor Stephen
Miller would write the speech and
would accord Lee read it from the
teleprompter there was no Trump writing
his speeches during the campaign that
was actually one of the things he was
most talented at at and when he started
using the teleprompter you could see
that those speeches started to go
downhill oh yeah they go downhill real
quick and lots of people suggesting
drinking games or even worse than
drinking with the speech for example
take a shot every time the word terrific
is used slap yourself in the face when
the phrase believe me is uttered will
you be participating in anything like
this I'm going to have to if it's if I'm
watching the inauguration of Donald
Trump even though it's gonna be around
noon on a Friday I got to do it one
suggestion online said snort cocaine
whenever Trump says he's humbled that
sounds very dangerous to me I don't
think that's gonna happen would Donald
Trump be humbled no yeah you probably
won't yeah at all our hospital system
does not have the capacity to handle the
repercussions of Trump universe in awe a
the Trump University is bad enough Trump
inauguration drinking games subject
matter
Trump is apparently going to focus on
structural problems not exactly red meat
for Republicans Pat's spending money on
infrastructure is it no not really and
when I look back on past presidential
inaugurations the more eloquent quotes
that past presidents have given for
example ask not what your country can do
for you ask away for what you can do for
your country yeah the only thing we have
to fear is fear itself
I wonder what Trump's gonna come up with
yeah I'm not anticipating anything
iconic like that although he might
insult someone in the crowd which would
at least be novel when it comes to an
inauguration speech you don't usually
see that will Trump speech be one that
brings people together and raises his
approval rating from its starting point
of 37 percent I guess if you go in at 37
and you end up lower after your speech
you really messed up something fierce
and I personally am both looking forward
to it but I don't it's gonna be insanely
depressing I am worried about my
emotional state after the speech well
it's happening whether we like it or not
thanks for watching this video before
you watch the next one remember we're
raising money to expand the David Pakman
show big league as well as expand
progressive activism go to david
pakman.com slash donate donations of any
size are much appreciated